it's great to be joined today by
urologist dr. Aaron Spitz who is a
national expert on men's health as well
as male sexual functioning male
fertility it's so great to speak to you
dr. Spitz I think our audience is going
to enjoy this or at least hopefully get
something useful out of it
we collected questions related to men's
health and men's sexual health over the
last few days and one question that
comes in very frequently and this may be
because of the age of many in our
audience sort of in their 30s is when do
you really need to start getting
prostate exams as a man and this is a
very sort of hopeful question is there a
less invasive version may be on the
horizon some kind of imaging that might
replace the digital test that that is
now done okay no those are those are
really important questions what we
currently are recommending is that for
most men they should start checking at
age 50 however if they are
african-american or they have a strong
family history of prostate cancer it
would make sense to start checking at
age 40 and the check is this digital
exam and digital sounds a little
misleading because it's not a computer
it's digit the finger and right now
there is not a better imaging substitute
for that that is reasonable for example
we are working on MRI imaging of the
prostate as a way to evaluate if a
cancer is present or not but that's very
impractical to try to use an MRI which
is an hour-long study at great expense
to replace really was just a moment of
inconvenience with the digital exam and
the MRI is not yet foolproof either but
it's not just a digital exam it's a
digital exam plus a PSA blood test the
PSA blood test has gotten a lot of bad
press but in a experienced doctors
practice who knows how to interpret the
test his exam and many men it
a very useful testament has saved many
many lakhs so again it's the combination
of the digital exam and a PSA blood test
starting at age 50 for most men starting
at age 44 men with high risk of prostate
cancer because of a strong family
history or because of being
african-american and these tests are
typically done yearly there's some
subtleties which may allow a person to
get it every other year but that's a
little bit more you know involved in the
discussion but suffice it to say those
are the guidelines okay
now when it comes to a condition like
prostate cancer or other prostate
related conditions whenever we talk
about cancer rates we always want to
keep in mind if we hear that a rate has
gone up has it actually gone up or are
we now categorizing some of these
diagnoses differently or are we better
at diagnosing conditions so barring all
of that in mind what is the data as you
understand it regarding whether the the
actual incidence of prostate cancer and
prostate related issues have increased I
believe that what we're seeing is that
when the PSA blood test first came out
we saw big increase in the number of
prostate cancers that were being
detected
but that wasn't necessarily that the
incidence had increased it was we had a
new way of detecting it earlier that's
all settled out and now the PSA blood
test is allowing us to pick up and
understand what the incidence of
prostate cancer is and the incidence is
about one in four men over the course of
their lifetime that's a real incidence
and prostate cancer is a very prevalent
problem amongst men now I'll tell you
something interesting and that the
incidence of prostate cancer seems to
vary in different populations around the
world and it seems that in the more
modern industrialized populations whose
diet is quite a bit different from say
world more agrarian populations there
does seem to be a higher incidence so
for example the populations and say
world China have a lower incidence of
prostate cancer than the population say
in
or urban setting like Hawaii and when
the Asians move from rural China to
Hawaii their children their children who
are genetically similar I have a much
higher incidence of prostate cancer
probably from this different environment
probably related in too many ways to the
diet so the incidence of prostate cancer
is rising as we become more
industrialized and as our diet shifts
however the incidence is not just
inherently rising on this program to
shift gears a little bit we often deal
with issues of religion and the way that
religion seeks to influence either
culture or government etc and a question
that came up frequently from our
audience
I think from people who expect the
answer to be one or another and will
give you the opportunity to answer in
the way you see fit there's often
religious opposition to masturbation
based strictly on medicine and
evidence-based analyses are there any
negative health repercussions to male
masturbation there are no negative
health repercussions to male
masturbation but masturbation is really
like most things in life if it is taken
to an extreme then it can be harmful not
in a physiological way but more in a
behavioral way so at its extremes there
are individuals who masturbate in a
particularly in a particular way with a
particular component that ultimately
interferes with their ability to be able
to have satisfactory sex or reach climax
or therefore even be able to ejaculate
for the purposes of conception with a
female partner with a vaginal
intercourse and that again is an extreme
example but otherwise masturbation has
no true physiologic health impact in any
negative way it's a it's a typically a
normal human experience I want to talk a
little bit about the relationship
between the sort of complaints that
just like you may hear from patients and
the interplay with sort of psychological
or psychosomatic conditions and I want
to sort of present to to you and you can
take them separately or together however
you see fit
one is a wreck tile dysfunction and we
know about the huge sort of
pharmaceutical industrial complex that
is developed around pills to treat
erectile dysfunction and I'd be
interested to hear from you in your
medical experience the the connection
between that condition and sort of
psychological or psychosomatic elements
and also frequent urination which is a
condition that often is increasingly
coming up in books about conditions like
headaches irritable bowel syndrome etc
which often are sort of diagnosed
amorphous ly not always associated with
a specific cause that some in the
medical community believe can be
actually reflections of sort of
emotional or psychological distress for
example what's your sense of that well I
think that the psychological components
of both of those conditions are much
more relevant in a younger population
like your viewers for example however
with regards to erectile dysfunction the
medical community suffered for many
years from the false notion that most of
it was psychological and it really
relegated most of the patients suffering
from erectile dysfunction to no real
remedy it is very much age-related when
you're looking at both of these
conditions and let's look at the Rexall
dysfunction portion then we'll take
frequent urination yeah erectile
dysfunction is most commonly experienced
by men in the later decades starting and
say the 50s 60s 70s and Beyond and with
each passing decade the percent chance
of a man will experience that gets
higher so for example about 50% of 50
year olds will experience it 60 percent
of 60 year olds 80% eighty year olds you
get the idea
and for the vast majority of men in that
age group it is physical not
well now certainly can have a
psychological feedback and then you can
set up a loo that makes it even worse
but the underlying physical component is
typically a problem with the blood flow
to the penis because an erection is
basically what flowing into the penis
expanding it filling and getting trapped
in there and then making it firmer and
firmer kind of like plumping up a tyre
and you have to have healthy blood
vessels nerves hormones
neurotransmitters all those things have
to be functioning and coordinating well
and as men get older there is a
deterioration in any a number of those
systems
throw in some diabetes throw in some
high blood pressure and understand that
the arteries that supply the blood to
the penis already very narrow to begin
with significantly smaller than the
arteries to our heart and as you know
men at fifty sixty seven eighty s suffer
from clogging of the arteries of the
heart clogging of the arteries to the
brain again much larger arteries and
heart attack and stroke are common we
know that's not psychological so it is a
physical condition and these pills do
increase the flow of blood of the penis
for these men and they work for many of
these men but in the younger population
men in their 20s and 30s
it is usually psychological and
behavioral and it can be very simple and
very subtle see adrenaline which our
body releases in order just to maintain
our resting blood pressure it's released
in surges when we are faced with danger
well when you're anxious and what
adrenaline does is it increases the
blood flow to our heart and lungs
gets us ready to deal with something but
it decreases the blood flow to the less
vital parts of our body which might be
our fingers our toes and our penis so
when a man experiences some trigger to
the adrenaline some anxiety and it may
be something as simple and subtle as I
wonder if I'm going to have trouble
getting an erection like I did last time
just a simple thought like that alone
can cause his body to release adrenaline
which then increases the flow of what
was pinis and prevents them from getting
an erection or from maintaining an
erection now it could be a much more
complex psychological trigger but it can
be a trigger just as simple as that and
even understanding
helm but that can be a hard thing to
tell yourself not to think about when
you tell yourself not to think about
something then of all you do is
perseverate on it yeah and even in these
psychological conditions these pills
which increase the flow of what the
penis can overcome the adrenaline effect
the adrenaline is trying to close the
blood vessels these pills keep the blood
vessels open and these pills can be
helpful in the psychological cases of
sort of getting somebody back to their
own self dusting themselves off having
some positive reinforcement having less
of that adrenaline release associated
with the context of about to have sex
and sort of get back to normal but
certainly behavioral medical approaches
to these patients is extremely valuable
even to the patients that have an
underlying physical because the
psychological component has also been
come into play they are going to have
anxiety about the inability to have
erections even their older and it's
physiologic and that's going to
reinforce the problem so I think that
there's certainly a very important role
for the behavioral approach for the
psychological of course but particularly
in the under population okay a few other
quick or I'm sorry go ahead yet did you
want to come in on frequent urination
yeah so when I come in for your nation
so like erectile dysfunction as men get
older they also have a physiological
tendency to have increased urination and
there's two reasons for that one is the
prostate gland which is like a tunnel
that surrounds the urethra as it goes
from the bladder into the penis part
when you're we grow it grows as we get
older and it squeezes inward and it
decreases the flow and when the flow
decreases the bladder which is a muscle
under its own autonomic control it's not
a muscly that you can consciously
control like your biceps for example
that muscle has to squeeze harder and
harder it gets thicker less compliant
can't hold as much goes on a
hair-trigger [ __ ] type low and wants
the empty urine more frequently even
though it's not going up as much and
that's a physiological situation in
older men in younger men yes there can
be a behavioral component
stress or some sort of behavioral issue
during the childhood how
but these are rare it's really rare that
it is a behavioral phenomenon if a young
person is having frequent urination you
really got to roll out real
physiological causes first and that
could be a stricture of the ureter from
previous sexual transmitted disease or
previous injury or previous urinary
tract infection or a prostatitis and
infection inflammation of the prostate
or a sexually transmitted disease that's
untreated or I have seen men who even
though their prostate is not enlarged
just the way their Anatomy works is
dysfunctional and their bladder neck is
closing off too much and it's a real
condition not psychological so it is
important to rule out the physiological
in frequent urination and for the vast
majority of older men men whose
prostates are getting large these pills
really work they relax the opening of
the urethra right where it comes off of
the bladder where the process run it and
they open things up with the urine flow
more easily and the bladder calms down
so the pills are very helpful in the
majority of these cases a few quick ones
in the limited time we have left
laptop on your lap rumors about this
reducing sperm count from the heat
anything to that well there may be um
there have been scientific studies that
show that you know heat deteriorates
from production we know for sure that it
deteriorates from production in certain
occupations where there's a significant
amount of heat firemen welders but
whether or not people who have laptops
on their laps actually have verifiable
lower birth rates has not been
established but I would say for anybody
who is struggling with achieving a
pregnancy who is keeping a laptop on
their lap for long durations of time get
it off why not decrease an insult
because we know that heat is a factor
that's why our testicles for us guys are
in our scrotum and not in our abdomen
like woman's ovaries because they
actually require to be a couple degrees
cooler than body temperature and if
you're going to be placing heat
throughout
we on them that sort of is you know
short-circuiting and that's also why
getting in a jacuzzi is not a good idea
if you're trying to establish a
pregnancy because that immersive heat
doesn't allow the testicles to pool
themselves now we do have mechanisms to
keep our testicles cool even if it gets
hot outside or even if we're exposing it
temporarily our scrotums get slack and
it drops our testicles further away from
our body in warm weather or warm water
when it's cold if our scrotum contracts
and pulls them closer to our warmer body
so we have mechanisms but when you put a
source of heat on top of them or you
immerse yourself in a source of heat you
sort of bypass that mechanism there's
also been some some notion that EMF
waves from cellphones or from electrical
equipment might impair our fertility and
there have been studies that shown that
sperm in the dish next to cell phone
signals do show some decline but whether
that actually translates to lower live
birth rates is not going to each other
last question real quick I'm fascinated
by scams is any pill pump or other
device going to actually enlarge the
size of a man's penis no matter what you
read in the back pages of a magazine
right so that's the question I get asked
most commonly by my friends there are no
pills that will enlarge the baseline
size of your penis the claims they make
for making your penis larger is simply
that they're inducing an erection and
yeah your penis gets larger when it's
erect and some of these pills actually
work by spiking their formula with
Viagra or Cialis and that's why they
worked so well as far as actually making
the resting size of your penis larger or
the size of your erection bigger than it
was before no pumps can increase the
size of your penis if your penis has
suffered some shrinkage from a condition
such as Peyronie's disease or from
souvenier erectile dysfunction when men
suffer from severe erectile dysfunction
they no longer get spontaneous erections
in the middle of the night and those
tissues tend to atrophy and using a
penile pump can stir
check back out and restore some of that
lost length whether or not a penis pump
will make your baseline normal erection
even bigger I really can't comment
because it's not part of the therapy I
recommend and I haven't really
encountered any men in my practice who
have told me that that indeed is the
case so I'm going to say probably not I
don't know but it can restore what has
contracted alright urologist dr. Aaron
Spitz you've truly said it all I don't
know that that that statement has has
ever been more true on the program I
really appreciate you talking to us
today it's my pleasure and if I can ever
be of help with other questions down the
line feel free to give me another call